I think there are several reasons I mean
I think clearly what you can't deny is
that bias and Prejudice still exists and
the legacy of bias and Prejudice has a
major impact that just doesn't go away
and you know I always go back if I could
rewrite history
yeah and say in just pick a an era in
the 1920s there was full equal
opportunity despite all that happened
historically
I think we would be so far ahead but
that didn't happen and so I think you've
got to deal with that issue I think
second is and this is part of what
Sheryl is talking about we can all
analyze the reasons why we can't get
ahead and we should be very focused on
that and we should all feel a collective
responsibility to change that but one of
the points when I was growing up that my
father emphasized with me was focus on
what you can what you can control and
the only thing you can control is your
performance there's several ways you can
look at that he was not saying that to
limit me what he was saying was that
opens up a range of opportunities and
from a accountability standpoint don't
in fact run away from that problem or
challenge or a barrier figure out a way
to jump over it
and so what Sheryl is certainly not
saying is that there are not a set of
major issues and big issues and
institutional issues that women have to
deal with but that women clearly can
take increasing ownership
for what they need to do that a support
structure is very helpful because we all
need a support structure and that's
important and that we got to take it
very personally I think at the end of
the day what's most important is there's
a surprising phenomenon that happens and
it's not really surprising when you get
people in positions who look different
and are different all of a sudden
several years later you get more people
who look like them and so the
representation issue is a big issue is
an important issue and it is at some
point and this is where I go to just
business metrics if someone is simply
saying each year can I'm gonna grow this
business is really going to do well here
are my strategies and each year nothing
happens
that's a problem so if there is a real
commitment and a real focus then there
need to be measures and there needs to
be accountability so that those things
happen and I think that a business
mentality around that it can bring about
some very important social change
you